[Music]
coronavirus
is not the great equalizer although it
can affect
anyone it hits the already vulnerable
the most
in brazil new favelas are springing up
overnight
gilma goncalves chavez is building a
provisional shelter for his family
before the crisis he worked as a day
laborer on construction sites
when work dried up the downward spiral
began
the landlord didn't want to wait he
wanted his money so he told us to move
out
we heard that a lot of people in our
situation were building shacks here
so we came here cleared a spot and are
doing the same thing
these improvised dwellings are crowded
and there are no toilets
health authorities worry that the living
conditions here could lead to a sharp
rise
in covid19 infections threatening their
livelihoods further
and thus completing the vicious cycle of
poverty and illness
[Music]
welcome to dw's kovid 19 special i'm
janelle demalaon thanks for joining us
poor in danger of getting sick and then
becoming even poorer
too many people are finding themselves
in the situation during the pandemic
but especially migrants are in a
particular bind with the governments of
their host countries often taking
insufficient responsibility for them
this next story takes us to the border
between nicaragua and costa rica
a blue steel fence is all that separates
costa rica from nicaragua here
elsewhere concrete posts mark the border
every morning nicaraguans cross the
frontier
to work on farms in costa rica
they are brought by truck to work
illegally on fruit
rice and bean plantations
they earn less than half the official
minimum wage
they've been doing it for decades but
now the border is closed because of the
global health emergency
gustavo from nicaragua counts himself as
one of the lucky ones
he's officially resident in costa rica
his wife is not but officials tested
them both for the coronavirus
the situation is worrying i've been
tested twice
thank god both results were negative but
two of my colleagues got infected
so now we have to be tested again
dozens of undocumented workers tested
positive at this border pineapple farm
only around a fifth are registered in
the costa rican social security system
they earn less than 400 a month working
12 hours a day
for many it's the only way they can feed
their families back home in nicaragua
where conditions can be much worse
the costa rican foundation areas for
peace
is critical of the poor treatment of the
nicaraguan migrant workers
it says exploitation is widespread
everybody knows about the smuggling
networks
everyone knows the woman who rents her
garden hose to the migrants
so they can wash their feet they all
know how much it costs
they all know about the taxi driver who
will tell the migrants when the police
have gone
or when they're taking a lunch break the
coronavirus has just
uncovered that reality
migrants pay trafficking networks as
much as two hundred dollars to smuggle
them across the border
ministers admit there's little they can
do about the illegal employment
the legal framework does not allow fines
to be imposed on business owners
who employ undocumented nicaraguan
harvest workers
for this we need a judicial decision on
whether there is a legal infringement
costa rica does not publish the
nationalities of coronavirus patients
but many blame the nicaraguan workers
for the growing number of kovid 19 cases
as well as raising tensions the pandemic
is highlighting the precarious
conditions
endured by migrants forced to cross
central america's borders
to find work professor hayodzieb of the
leibniz institute for
prevention research and epidemiology
joins us now
professor tsib you've written about how
the risks and consequences of this
pandemic are unevenly distributed
socioeconomically speaking we've seen in
this report how especially vulnerable
migrants are
and yet so many countries depend on
migrant labor from around the world what
can be done to protect them
so first of all i think we have to
basically respect their contribution to
you know
economy to society and so forth so that
means
um help them to be able to cope with the
epidemic just as
many countries try to do for the
citizens living in the country anyways
so
that means inform them first of all
allow them
help them to you know take those
protective measures that are needed
improve working conditions such that
distancing is
a possible ensure that the living
conditions are okay
migrant workers often live under very
precarious conditions
in crowded accommodations and these are
the things that we can really
do now to support those communities and
make sure that they can really also
you know get the best out of the
protective measures that are out there
that coronavirus exacerbates inequality
as something that's becoming clear
is there any way to address this issue
at a time where
we still don't have a vaccine i think it
does relate to what i was saying just
before that we now have to make sure
that the conditions are there that
these groups uh people with low
socioeconomic resources and so forth
that
are they are able to really cope with
the situation as best as possible
we have seen for example in the in the
us that uh
now the support the weekly support was
cut and immediately i mean the
issues of unemployment come up and this
is particularly precarious for
for groups with you know low income and
precarious jobs
they lose the little income they may
have and then they slip into real
major economic but also social problems
and that also means health problems
because they will be having
you know a harder time to find care if
they need it they may have
less access to the testing facilities
and all this is really something that
needs to be taken care of now and
once a vaccine comes another big issue
is to make sure that it reaches
especially groups under you know major
or higher risks than other groups that
will also be a big challenge
so as you say poverty leads to health
problems leads to more poverty
what does worsening inequality mean for
the ability of the world's health
systems to cope with this crisis
unfortunately often
more socio-economic groups with we know
with with lower resources
they also suffer more from let's say
chronic conditions
and those chronic conditions are exactly
now
those that make survival or let's
say the the cause of the kobe disease
more severe so we may have this
situation
that people with low socioeconomic
status
actually will be suffering more from
copied and they are also at risk in the
work condition so these are the things
that the health systems will definitely
see
and as as more cases occur and there
will be more
severe cases among people with low in
opportunities to protect themselves and
who may have already pre-com
pre-existing conditions we'll see more
really severe sick people getting into
the
uh hospitals that need to be taken care
of who need to be taken care of
and not all systems will be able to cope
with this
now this isn't the world's first
pandemic some experts say
it won't be the last so what lessons can
we derive from today that would help
shield those in situations
most precarious from the worst effects
of the pandemic
we do see this so often in in you know
diseases be it chronic or infectious
diseases coming up that
we have uh social differences in the
disease risk and in the disease course
so this is nothing new
and we just need to be acting more
swiftly and in the beginning already you
know be
aware and and realize that this is what
is going to come
that we will have uh groups that are
particularly affected by
such a pandemic and we need to start
having structures that really allow
swift and action that really brings
those those issues that are there out in
the open immediately at the beginning of
such
pandemics so that we can care for people
much better that we have
you know ability the ability to you know
look at these working conditions
um change for example the working and
living conditions of migrants
immediately and that shouldn't be
actually a task for
pandemics only but in general but it's
hard and to get the politicians
doing this we have been trying here in
germany um
it is a slow process but it needs to be
done and it needs to be done before the
next
wave of the this epidemic or even future
time to act thank you very much
professor hayotseeb of the leibniz
institute for prevention research and
epidemiology
thanks for your analysis thank you
now you get to ask the questions here's
our science correspondent derek williams
[Music]
i've heard researchers talk about trying
to mute the immune response but also
saying that a younger
stronger immune system is more
successful in fighting off covid19
isn't that a contradiction to understand
the apparent contradiction here you have
to understand
that there are are different stages of
covid19 that that patients can go
through
the first is usually an initial
infection
in the upper respiratory tract and and
that's usually
where it stays with most people um
that's where having
a strong fast-acting immune system
is really great it's it's able to keep
the disease in check
and eventually wipe it out in some cases
it keeps it so effectively in check
that you might not even notice that you
had it
but in more severe forms of the disease
if the virus
eventually makes it to the lungs or to
other organs
it can kick in a severe immune response
and and when that happens the immune
system can start attacking
not just disease tissue but but healthy
tissue
as well that's when doctors have to step
in
and and try to mute the immune response
with drugs because
if it spirals out of control it can kill
you
but striking a balance between letting
the immune system do its job
and and raining it in if it spins out of
control
is is pretty tricky
[Music]
now there's nothing like a glass of
lemonade on a hot day
in london two enterprising six-year-olds
are selling cups of the juice to help
with yemen's humanitarian crisis
in just six weeks the boys have raised
more than fifty thousand dollars
yemen is reeling from the impact of a
devastating war and the rapid spread of
coronavirus
it's all from their own recipe but the
boys are keeping that
a secret for now
you